[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes prêt est entré dans
les profondeurs de l'enfer
nat
non mais t'es sérieuses dès lors c'est
halloween
j'ai des pass vip pour le hellfest c'est
quoi ça on se fait peur toute la nuit
dans des labyrinthes tout le monde
flippe sa race
on va s'éclater pourquoi ont signé une
décharge pour éviter les problèmes
ils sont obligés il ya deux ans une
fille a été complètement éventrées le
tueur la laisser dans le parc elle est
restée là trois jours les gens croyaient
que c'était un mannequin il ya des
malades
il se balade parmi nous
on a compris la mode tu crois que tu me
fais peur non bougez plus tu as l'air
d'avoir peur pluies vont venir vers toi
au cul la joue cool et des mois mais
vas-y
c'était trop tordu savent a l'air
tellement rire
[Musique]
ce gars nous a suivi toute la soirée
ok tu prends ton boulot trop au sérieux
franchement c'est pas drôle
[Musique]
vous êtes venus pour avoir peur non je
vais pas arrêter les gars parce qu'ils
font leur boulot
bienvenue au hellfest
[Musique]
m
à vous les week-ends dignité
[Musique]
lights most people to ne sait
l'eau
non
certains y vont
à toi tu regardes c'est non
le moment est venu de faire revivre le
parc une nouvelle journée commence au
parc des merveilles toute l'équipe se
prépare bomer l'ours dacca you steve le
responsable de la sécurité
on dort debout les bras à l'intérieur du
véhicule et pin est l'inventeur
d'attraction nous allons inaugurer le
grand manège
je suis sûr qu'on peut faire mieux
oui tu as raison je crois que pinata
plus d'imagination des poissons des
poissons volants et en accueillant sur
leurs nageoires
on pourrait voler au dessus du parc type
à quelques fois que le parc existant
vrai mais oui pourquoi pas
tu peux réaliser tout ce que tu imagines
paramount animations et nickelodeon
movies présente
qu'est ce que ça fait là
ici le parc de vos rêves
je suis dans le parc des merveilles
m
mais réalité sens tu peux rien ne m'a
donc pas
on skiera bâton se carapate bon allez on
se calme je m'appelle jaune j'ai inventé
le parc des merveilles quand j'étais
petit
pourquoi tu as choisi importe pic pour
assurer la sécurité
j'ai l'impression de m'être engagé dans
une impasse arrière toute pub le 3 avril
je comprends pas ce qui est arrivé ici
en grandissant les enfants ne croient
plus aux histoires et l'imagination
disparaît c'est comme ça que le rêve a
tourné au cauchemar n'en rajoute pas
attendre
[Musique]
pour faire renaître la magie le moment
est venu de faire revivre le parc
on est en train d'ajouter un miracle
l'imagination prend le pouvoir et des
noms
vous avez bien bloquer les routes les
routes ça sert à bloquer les routes ça
bon
[Musique]
mais tout le monde 31 ans
à ce stade et je crois que l'on peut
parler de situation désespérée et non je
coupure le parc des merveilles autres
rencontres au cinéma le 3
laissez moi vous raconter quand j'étais
petit j'avais presque le même bateau
tous les étés ans se baladait sur le lac
il y avait de l'amour
nous étions famille ont passé des
moments merveilleux ont coulé en voiture
c'est pas vrai il d'un coup j'ai dit
quelque chose
qu'est ce qui vous tient sa place à ce
n'est ni un virus ni une attaque
chimique
c'est le mal absolu ils ont vu des
créatures qui peuvent prendre la forme
de ce qu'on redoute le plus à chaque
fois qu'on entre en contact avec
l'extérieur
il y a des morts
personne n'est venu me chercher pour me
recevait alou nous avons un endroit
c'est un lieu sûr pour nous rejoindre il
faut descendre la rivière les oiseaux
vous avertirons chaque fois que c'est
quelque chose s'approcheront
[Musique]
on va devoir partir neuf ans
mais n'enlevez jamais vos bateaux
on s'en sortir
[Musique]
quand les enfants et partez
je vais pas te laisser tout seul
prenez pas mes enfants non non non
monsieur je parle à mes enfants
il est vital
maintenant
je ne savais pas quoi
c'est le pen tu as vu et leur pris du
poids et il a retrouvé sa petite
étincelle dans les yeux ça se voit il va
beaucoup mieux alors pourquoi tu caches
tout nos affaires on avait dit qu'on
revivrai pas ça tu te souviens tu as une
journée demain à cet art si tu repars en
désintox
ok je ne quitterai pas des yeux une
seconde c'est clair c'est bien rentrer à
la maison
si tu me connaissait vraiment tu
voudrais plus jamais revoir connaît non
maman tu ne connais pas tout ce que je
veux c'est que tu fasses un dernier
petit truc pour moi
ceci est mon fils comme ayant pas il
faut que tu rentres à la maison n'ont
pas sans peine
retrouvez mon fils fait aussi pas mal
tout ce que je me suis infligé à moi et
aux autres
peut pas les sauver mais tu t'en voudra
toute ta vie si tu ne sais pas
ou est ce que tu veux que je tentais
leur dis moi tu as donc tout
à mourir
enfin bref voilà je suis toujours là
alors merci à tous merci beaucoup
[Musique]